all right
um excellent work very very good
keep this in mind as you keep going
forward
to do the internal aspects is to work at
what I have called the energetic
component
[Music]
that means it's not muscular
it is not skeletal
hence it's not going to be bracing
angles
and
um
simply moving somebody's line of gravity
outside of someone's base of support
that stuff is important but
you want to make sure this is also
included
so the first thing I want to to remind
you and everyone here
at the energetic level you have two
energies yin and yang
they are designated culturally in this
Poetics
I call them Poetics because they're not
energy
like momentum or inertia or gravity
because they're not mechanical
they weren't this
poet this Poetics was not generated
in a culture
based in secular materialism
so I made a post recently
uh in the Aikido group and one guy said
energy is like its energy is energy like
in physics no that's not true
yin and yang
has a metaphysical component
because mind and body
are not separated in pre-modern culture
this is not
a mechanical Theory
based in a materialistic philosophy
that's not true
so Yin energy
is corresponded with various things and
I'll list those correspondence to you
but I'll also give you a reference point
to work with okay so Yin energy is heavy
and sinks Yin energy is
coming from below because it sinks so
it's related to the energy of the Earth
it's related to the lower portions of my
body
it's related to symbolically or
poetically water
and the water region is in the lower
portion of my body down here
young energy is in the chest region of
my body is related corresponded to
heaven
and related to fire
poetically
you might see
the water lower region
is associated with the turtle
and the chest upper region is associated
with the Phoenix
what you're trying to do
is mix
these two
elements
because
in the mixing of them
they become indistinguishable
and this is energetically a
Reconciliation of the two
Aikido
has
aikidokihonawaza has a particular mixing
pattern that is repeated over and over
again
so
energy chest from above young is going
to meet
Yin From Below
energy in my body
therein is the tanden
tanden like other Concepts in pre-modern
culture is an apophatic term it's not a
place in my body like a lot of moderns
think when they talk about it use your
tonden aim your time you don't have a
taunted
until you can internalize yin and yang
and until they meet
in the midpoint of your body now you
have a taunted now you have a field
where yin and yang can be mixed to be
reconciled and indistinguishable from
each other
that's what your tandem is
so the pattern
of the mixing
is the rotating cross
that you've seen me mention many many
times
so I'm going to uh maybe you want to
come more in front maybe you need to
come around so you can see me
let us
say use this Band-Aid on this ball
as a reference point okay
the yin and yang energy is going to mix
this way first
then up
you see
cut it
then back the other one
and then down
you got it
I'll do it again
it's gonna go one way so in this case I
would be throwing to my left
the energy inside my body is going to
first mix to my right
it's going to go up
it's going to mix to the left
and then it's going to go down
okay
so now come here
this point was made in the kokudosa
video
so his pushing is Young energy
you can see how deota
aims it in the chest do you think that
this is this is technically
but only at a physiological level
this is
a energetic component level it's in my
chest
okay
I am going to Vector that down bounce it
off the ground
and that's where the mixing starts with
the Earth Energy the yinchi got it
dot oh now it's in my body meeting here
down now I have a tandem field
now what I do push
I'll feel the expansion of the Tom Den
as those energies are expanding and
pressing on each other and now I rotate
that I'm going to exaggerate it now I'm
gonna I'm gonna throw this way to my
left I'm going to rotate it
to the right
bring it up
you see
bring it back to the left
and then bring it down
if I was going to my right
it'll go to the left
up
over to the right and then down
against your back
knowing that come back to the physical
component
that rotation
has a physical component and as you get
more skilled less and less of the
physical component is necessary
but
the physical component is never going to
manifest in the waste
I'll show you what that looks like in
the waist
I'm going to turn my waist do you think
you got it I'm gonna lift up
I'm going to turn my waist again and
then I crunch down
that is going to compress
that Tom denfield
and you're going to lose it
you do not rotate in your waist never
ever
that physical component
rotation is in the quad
so I want you to focus
on those seams
between your thigh and your pelvis
so I remember here I don't go like that
that's in my waist and it it to me it
feels like the normal pressurizing
expanding of the yin and yang
good
gets squashed like a balloon that you
squeeze it and the energy the air goes
out do you understand
so it's down here if you pay attention
my waist does not move do you see my
waist does not move here's my waist
moving
my waist does not move I move the quad
you see that I move the clock
my waist
my shoulders do not rotate counter to my
hips waist
waist
you see that
waist waist okay so I do the technique
and the claw goes this way
but inside
that she is going that way
[Music]
point to you
because
all about focusing on the qua you're
gonna do all the other stuff but it's
about the claw
it's not somebody attacking you in a
Japanese restaurant
it's to take the leg component out
so you have to use the quad
so if you're going to do it go ahead and
stand up
and you're gonna do the inward spiral
don't have your waist or your elbow do
the movement
the qua moves the qua moves
the quad moves
and eventually what you're trying to do
is less and less internal
just the chi mood
when you come to tachiwasa
the claw still moves
the waist does not move
and you still are going to make that
pattern so we've been working on
sumitosh
I'm going to throw him let's answer the
question reverse engineer the pattern of
the rotating cross we get to the end
I am going to throw him
which way
this way
do you understand
so
my cross is going to rotate here I'm
doing
the initial feed but here it goes
watch my watch mice the chico this part
is just to bring him into range but it
also
she's going this way
where's the ball
[Music]
there it goes this way first
around
boom she goes this way to the right
you see but not my waist
the qua
you see not not my
shoulders
whoa plant right should I push down here
no what do I gotta do
I have to go up going up is what allows
his Center to move forward
you see if you if I'm here
and I go down his Center can't move
forward
and I need a center to go forward so
that when I hold his elbow back he has
the following geometry so all of you
here there are coming back like this and
Shove It Down
you basically did this
that
you see
so he has to come up there it is then
down
boom boom
okay
um
sorry
picture this goes around
comes up
right then
around
and then down
okay got it all right let's try it
[Music]
so uh remember
that the ground is energy from here goes
down I need the ground energy to balance
and come off okay it's not going to come
up on its own do you understand it's not
it's yin's gonna stay down the Earth is
going to stay down there okay so I'll
have to balance his energy off push okay
and all that is grounded push push push
push all that is grounded as I move push
push push knock me over push grounded
boom
one push this ground ground ground
push
boom
okay
to do that
can have stiff arms
that's nice
[Music]
same way
can't have stiff legs
like
my body pushed my body is very supple
foreign
this claw
is going out
and it needs to go in
got it
so foot knee hip
Stay Together
[Music]
this
so here here we are the quad is going to
open here
push
push qua opens here push this way
and then increasing
with my foot matching
not against
cool
okay try it again
on this technique I have my pattern so
that she rotates to the right she writes
rotates up
then back to the left she rotates to the
right she goes up rotate it back to the
left and down
what I'm seeing is your cheese going
down and then to the right that's that's
not the pattern you're not mixing it
the right way because perv is not being
mixed okay
so the throw
happens I won't do when you're mistaking
what I mean is you you see his my arm
but I'm not throwing anymore I'm just
staying with him
the throat already happened
the watch where his elbow is
when we
separate
you're not going to see his elbow
out on the side
his elbows behind him
can you see it
elbows behind him
okay
don't pull him to the outside
put